this is the main hospital in Sudan's
blue now State and it's filled with
survivors of renewed violence between
the hausa and Berta tribes it's left the
hospital with many to tend to and not
enough to assist those in need according
to local authorities at least 220 have
been killed in days of fighting and more
than 200 have been injured and thousands
have been displaced
in the first assessment there are 2004
families in four schools and some 2000
in other places each family has an
average of five to six people so with
that you can estimate how large the
displacement is
the violence has sparked protests with
demonstrators storming the military
headquarters in Blue Nile State they
also stormed the local government
headquarters demanding the resignation
of the governor authorities have
declared a one-month state of emergency
in the State security forces have been
deployed to the areas that witnessed
fighting and the curfew has been imposed
the tension between the hausa and Berta
communities began in July sparked by a
dispute about land claims at least 140
were killed then and more than 40 000
displaced but tensions escalated once
again this month leading to the
temporary closure of the main markets in
the state capital temazine local
authorities say there is a need for
humanitarian assistance for those who've
been affected
these displaced are now in schools as
large groups these habitats are not fit
to be camps doesn't have the proper
health conditions there are a lot of
complications and we can't handle the
situation because the flow of displaced
is still ongoing that is why we are
calling on Aid organizations and
friendly countries and the federal
government to send the necessary Aid
most of those in need are in remote
areas and Aid organizations say it's
difficult to reach them but even those
who are close to help are still waiting
hoping more medical assistance arrives
before they run out of time people
Morgan Al Jazeera